&gt;&gt; Well I, for one, have a pretty tough time trying to think about an infinite
number of numbers. It would be great if we had a straightforward way to
visualize this. Luckily, someone had the awesome idea to invent the number line,
which is this wonderful visual device right here. A number line is basically a
way of displaying all of the real numbers. We can represent whatever number or
range of numbers we want to on the number line just by shading in certain
positions on it. For example, since this dot is at the hash mark for negative 4,
I have just plotted negative 4 on this number line. Even though I've shown the
integers on this number line, we can also plot any point in between two
integers, which is why all the real numbers can be shown on the number line.
Notice that just like on the x-axis of a coordinate plane, numbers increase as
we move to the right and decrease as we move to the left. I've labeled three
points on this number line, A, B, and C. And I'd like you now to tell me what
you think that each of these are equal to. What do you think the values at all
three points are?